Das ist wahrscheinlich der Fall,
der wie kein zweiter
die Praxis des Justizvollzugs in Zürich
und der ganzen Schweiz verändert hat.
Frank Urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
Gerichtspsychiater der Schweiz.
Wenn die Medien Fragen haben, liefert er Antworten.
Wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten Fälle mit denen er als
Gutachter zu tun hatte.
1993 ermordete ein Insasse der
Justizvollzugsanstalt Pöschwies
auf einem bewilligten Hafturlaub
die 20-jährige Pasquale Brumann
in Zürich Zollikerberg.
Der Täter war zu einer lebenslangen
Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt,
die er absass.
Er hatte zu diesem Zeitpunkt
bereits etliche Eigentumsdelikte begangen,
elf Vergewaltigungen
und zwei Sexualmorde.
Der Verdacht fiel sofort auf Erich Hauert.
Denn der grausame Mord
trug eine klare Handschrift,
die der Polizei von Hauerts
früheren Verbrechen bekannt war.
Überführt wurde er mit Hilfe von Blutspuren
an seiner Armbanduhr.
Als klar war, dass dieses Blut der
ermordeten Pasquale Brumann gehörte,
gestand er die Tat.
Man hat es hier eindeutig
mit dieser Art von Tätern zu tun,
die extrem gefährlich
und lebenslang unbehandelbar sind.
Es zeigt sich eine solche
massive Brutalität
und eine Penetranz der Gewalt.
Man sieht eine
chronifizierte Vergewaltigungs-Disposition
zusammen mit der Bereitschaft zu töten.
Das ist tief in der Persönlichkeit
verwurzelt.
Es hat zu ganz vielen Delikten geführt.
Das ist mit einer solchen Penetranz
in der Persönlichkeit verankert,
da geht es nicht um Therapie,
sondern darum,
die Bevölkerung langfristig
vor solchen Tätern zu schützen.
Der Fall erschüttert die Schweiz.
Wie ist es möglich, dass
einem solchen Menschen
unbegleitete Hafturlaube bewilligt werden?
Und er weiter morden kann?
Die Verantwortlichen erklären
den unbegleiteten Hafturlaub damit,
dass Hauert trotz lebenslänglicher Freiheitsstrafe
bald hätte entlassen werden müssen.
Darauf habe man ihn vorbereiten wollen.
Wir haben in der Strafanstalt
rund 35 Gewalt- und Sexualstraftäter.
Täter, die für die Öffentlichkeit
ein Gefährdungspotential darstellen.
In der Regel haben diese Täter
eine Strafe zwischen 10 und 14 Jahren,
nur ein einziger hat eine
«lebenslängliche» Strafe.
In den letzten dreissig Jahren
gab es keinen einzigen Fall,
in dem die Strafe
komplett vollzogen wurde.
Sie wurden immer nach
15 bis 16 Jahren entlassen.
Das sind unabhängige Gerichte,
die ein solches Urteil sprechen.
In diesem Fall hat die
Justizbehörde
eine Verwahrung beantragt,
der Staatsanwalt hat eine
Verwahrung beantragt.
Das Gericht hat die mildere
Strafe beschlossen,
die lebenslängliche
Freiheitsstrafe.
Urbaniok kam zwei Jahre nach
diesem Mord in die Schweiz
und stellte schnell fest,
dass diese Erklärungen zu kurz griffen.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Verzerrung
der tatsächlichen Verhältnisse.
Das ist doppelt falsch.
Zum einen muss man sagen,
gab es keinen Hinderungsgrund,
lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe,
auch lebenslang zu vollziehen.
Das wäre rechtlich möglich gewesen,
aber die Praxis war halt anders.
Zum zweiten war es so,
dass die Verwahrungen,
die damals ausgesprochen wurden,
dazu führten, dass die Täter in aller
Regel nach drei oder vier Jahren
entlassen wurden.
Das führte zur paradoxen
Reaktion der Gerichte,
dass die Gerichte aufgrund dieser Praxis
gesagt haben,
bevor der gefährliche Täter
nach drei oder vier Jahren
wieder auf der Strasse steht,
beantragen wir lieber eine
endliche Freiheitsstrafe,
von fünf, zehn, zwölf Jahren – dann ist er länger drin.
Was natürlich das Problem
nur zeitlich nach hinten verschoben hat.
Ich würde sagen,
die Analyse ist falsch
und eine, die die wirklichen
Probleme eher zudeckt, als aufdeckt.
Der Fall Hauert hat laut Urbaniok
einen Systemfehler
des damaligen Strafvollzuges offengelegt.
Das grosse Problem sei gewesen,
dass eine Art ideologische Brille
vielen Verantwortlichen die Sicht
auf die Realität verzerrt habe.
Die 68er sind eine Zeit in der
wichtige gesellschaftliche Reformen
angestossen worden sind,
in denen man viele Sachen
überdacht hat.
Jahre, in denen man verkorkste,
autoritäre Strukturen
hinterfragt und verändert hat.
Das ist auch sicherlich
ein Verdienst der 68er,
aber die Zeit hat auch ihre Nebenwirkungen
und Schattenseiten.
Im Strafvollzug wurde die Idee propagiert,
dass die gesellschaftlichen Zustände
Kriminalität produzieren.
Nach dem alten marxistischen
Grundsatz,
das Sein prägt das Bewusstsein.
In dieser Optik steht nicht der
Einzelfall im Zentrum,
sondern es ist eher etwas Globales.
Jeder hat eine Chance verdient.
Wir müssen sehen, dass wir beruflich qualifizieren,
dann begehen die Menschen auch
keine Delikte mehr.
Das sind die Schattenseite dieser
teilweise etwas naiven Haltung,
alle Straftäter sind irgendwie die gleichen,
sind Symptome einer Zeit,
sind Symptome einer Gesellschaft.
Dazu muss man sagen,
dass man Kriminalitätsursachen
vor allem
am Einzelfall
festmachen muss.
Da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Menschen,
ganz unterschiedliche Täter,
ganz unterschiedliche Risiken,
unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten,
darauf einzuwirken.
Dieser Differenzierungsschritt
hat damals gefehlt,
in einer generell reformatorischen Euphorie,
dass man die ganze Welt besser macht,
womit dann Risiken in dieser Optik
wenig in den Blick genommen wurden.
Der Mord in Zollikerberg erschütterte
den Schweizer Strafvollzug
in seinen Grundfesten.
Es blieb fast kein Stein
auf dem anderen.
Der Schutz der Öffentlichkeit
vor gefährlichen Tätern
wurde zur ersten Priorität.
Es hat dazu geführt,
dass man Risikobeurteilungen
standardmässig professionalisiert hat.
Dass man gesagt hat,
man muss sich um
das Risiko Gedanken machen.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass die Therapien
deliktorientiert durchgeführt wurden.
Nicht mehr die Mutter stand
im Zentrum
oder irgendwelche alltäglichen
Kleinigkeiten,
sondern vor allem das Deliktverhalten.
Auch die Bewährungshilfe hat sich verändert,
sie wurde risikoorientiert ausgerichtet.
Wenn man früher eher die Tendenz hatte,
dass der Bewährungshelfer
ein Kumpel ist,
dann ist der Bewährungshelfer
seit dieser Zeit ein Fachmann,
der sich mit Risiken auskennt und
die Risikozeichen erkennen kann.
Eine andere grosse Entwicklung ist
die Differenzierung im Strafvollzug.
Klassischer Strafvollzug kommt
aus der Idee,
dass alle das gleiche
Programm haben.
Wir kennen das aus dem Fernsehen:
Alle haben die gleichen Klamotten an,
haben das gleiche Essen.
Dahinter ist die Haltung,
dass wenn drinnen
Ruhe und Ordnung herrschen,
hat der Strafvollzug seine
Pflicht und Schuldigkeit getan.
Wenn man sich das überlegt,
weiss man aber, dass es ganz
unterschiedliche Tätergruppen
im Strafvollzug gibt.
Hier ist der Drogenkurier aus Kolumbien,
da der Pädosexuelle
oder der Sexualmörder.
Das sind ganz unterschiedliche
Problemstellungen.
Man hat dann angefangen zu sagen,
dass man den Strafvollzug
differenzieren muss.
Andere Tätergruppen ergeben
andere Problemstellungen.
Darauf muss man sich einrichten.
Ganz wesentlich war die
Erkenntnis,
dass die Pflicht und Schuldigkeit
nicht mit der Entlassung aufhört.
Man hat gesagt, dass man auch
Verantwortung
für die Zeit nach dem Strafvollzug übernehmen muss.
Das sind einige der fundamentalen
Änderungen,
die sich vollzogen haben,
und die das System in der Tiefe
verändert haben.
Die Verwahrungsinitiative wurde angenommen,
eine grosse Überraschung.
Hochrisiko-Täter lebenslang wegsperren,
das bekräftige das Stimmvolk 2004
mit dem Ja zur Verwahrungsinitiative.
Mit der Umsetzung dieser Initiative
tut sich die Justiz schwer.
Aber sie führte zu einer
generellen Verschärfung
der Verwahrungspraxis.
Wer heute verwahrt wird,
der hat kaum eine Chance,
je wieder entlassen zu werden.
Sicherlich ist es so,
dass das Pendel in die andere
Richtung geschwungen ist,
und dass man sehr sensibilisiert
für Risiken ist.
Ich glaube sogar,
dass man an einigen Stellen
das System überdreht.
Das ist ganz sicher so.
Ich bin ein grosser Fan von
Differenzierung,
nicht von entweder/oder –
schwarz/weiss,
sondern dass man den Einzelfall
anschaut.
Im Einzelfall dann die angemessenen
Massnahmen treffen.
Das kann auch mal eine
lebenslange Verwahrung sein.
Das kann in vielen Fällen aber
etwas ganz anderes sein.
Aber es muss immer
verhältnismässig,
fair am Einzelfall festgemacht werden.
Da kann man Entwicklungen beobachten,
wo durch bürokratische Prozesse
und komplizierte Abläufe,
die Entscheidungswege so lange
und kompliziert werden,
dass der eine oder andere unverdienterweise
im System hängen bleibt.
Das ist genauso zu kritisieren,
und rechtsstaatlich genauso bedenklich,
wie wenn auf der anderen Seite
Fehler passieren.